I got the confidence in fact on the
interviews I received around 80 to 90
percent of
it I am based out of Pune and currently
working in as a QA analyst in PTC I have
experience of 3.6 years now in service
based company as well as product base
come previously I worked in TCS as some
Engineers I have worked upon manual
testing as well as automatic testing so
basically I have worked on many many of
the tools like selenium rest assured
so that was a great experience I found
the catalog very helpful there are many
kind of things which were covered inside
this course like please God about the
automation testing in every domain like
it was automation testing course for UI
automation Plus mobile automation plus
rest automation plus performance testing
so we we do not get this kind of
versatile codes anywhere in the market
according to me
I got the confidence in practice down
the interviews and uh and going into an
organization which would give me a role
that I like to cook too that was a
change in my life and uh and I am
receiving many compliments also my
seniors like I I don't think very
earlier I have very easily the new
things the challenging things also I got
new challenging projects which are
trending Technologies like iot I am
working on it is a trending technology I
I got a decent amount of salary and
equipment I received around uh 80 to 90
percent of surveys
[Music]
actually I am not from the IIT domain I
am actually from electronics and
communication domain so the uh so the
coding skills were not as much great
like the it or CS peoples so because of
this course I got Temple amount of
experience to invest those time into uh
into learning uh a programming language
like Java so those kind of skills I am
using in my day to day life and I am
visiting it very easily it is a very
versatile learning for the interviews
were very helpful like I was having much
confidence in each and every skills but
that interviewer asked to deliver from
myself and not only the interviews uh
when you join a company as the new
Joiner you you need to learn new things
and if you if you do this kind of
courses or you have an experience of
learning new things so you will adopt
those things very quickly so that was a
big plus point that I received from this
course
foreign
[Music]